hey yo I'm back I'm back I'm doing vlogs
again my dick is average size I see this
a lot of freestyle I don't
Oh what is going on YouTube now recently
I've noticed an interesting trend
apparently everybody on the Internet is
an expert murder right that's right
y'all ever notice every time you're
right or do something on the internet
there is some dumb [ __ ] that tells you
how to do something that they know
nothing about piss me off better mind
your business but step or your dip your
belly button social media has now given
all these stupid people a voice and now
I'm hitting ngq man and your McCain and
should be kick y'all so y'all ready know
what it is else y'all baby let's get it
let's go if you're gonna write to
somebody how stupid they are
maybe you should spell check your [ __ ]
now you know [ __ ] somebody else stupid
when you got 14 typos in a seven word
sentence the [ __ ] you talking with John
knuckles [ __ ] tell me why when you text
you look like this ah do you know what
that little red squiggly line under your
words mean that doesn't mean you're
doing a good job it's a typo fix that
[ __ ] you got so many typos [ __ ] look
like it's in a different language for
the game so good called popiah [ __ ] hey
no man what the hell white boy type
invent the money hey [ __ ] everybody
loves to hate on social media especially
about [ __ ] they know nothing about you
ever noticed that it is always a fat
person that loves to give weight loss
advice personally at the fat person can
I ask you something how the [ __ ] would
you know if you knew so much about
weight loss why you look like Missy
Elliott before her gastric bypass now
the other day I was checking out my
homegirls Instagram and she put up a
video of her working out and this one
hatin [ __ ] wrote em again
what at jail she doesn't know and she's
doing so in my mind I'm like well this
girl's talking [ __ ] so she must be thick
wrong that [ __ ] was huge
once again coming from a fat person how
the [ __ ] would you know and check this
out there she writes you don't even know
my BMI or how fat I am
[ __ ] you on Instagram we can see your
picture dumbass [ __ ] own- ass
personality [ __ ] you so ugly even your
filter be like personally I'm trying to
understand something why are you going
out of your way to be negative and put
someone else down like I'm doing right
now [ __ ] one thing I hate the most is
when a fat person doesn't know that that
fat of it I know it look if you big and
you know it and you love it
enjoy it to the fullest my you go walk
around criticizing other people about
the fitness when you look at a box of
pizza like yourself order that's just
like the other day without walking
around and this homeless dude try to
give me financial advice a good you want
to know how to get rich how the [ __ ]
would you know and what is every person
on Twitter and Facebook want to quote
somebody when they don't know who the
hell is from oh what the hell it means
egg out to be or not to be that is the
question a word who wrote that dog was
that me her name is a Malcolm Luther
King my god you dumb you know what dudes
put up quotes on their facebook because
they think it'll get them [ __ ] letting
go get you girls you know what might
help you though a [ __ ] job acting
like you educate you went to jail twice
for robbing the Toys R Us [ __ ] we know
you can't read
there's nothing all those murderers
rapists and thugs that got Bible verses
tattooed across their chests why what
you think when you die Jesus gonna be
like uh says here you murder seventeen
people but that Bible verse on yo dick
you're in do so stupid he thought the
Holocaust of the price the holiday girl
look don't get it twisted people I think
people blame social media for the reason
why people are getting more dumb every
day and that's just not true
it's not that there's more stupid people
it's just that social media has now
given a route for stupid people to voice
their opinions to the world cuz before
social media nobody really had a listen
to the [ __ ] we just give them the finger
and walk the [ __ ] away
but now every single dumbass is
connected to the same forum and for some
reason we can't help but read their [ __ ]
I'll bet all your hating [ __ ] I'm
gonna criticize my video now aren't you
honey
he'll guess what I'm gonna do I'm a
hashtag something for you hashtag go
[ __ ] yourself god I'm just gonna bring
it in from us pick it up hashtag no homo
hashtag love me [ __ ] hashtag this is
awkward
hello there baby
how happen
some time since I couldn't call you
[Music]
you left me
when winter came you flew some rest
[Music]
why should I stay
[ __ ] you got so many typos [ __ ] look
like it's a diffusion never notice that
it is always up Oh Oh God
get up [ __ ] laughing outside [ __ ] man